[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States Donald J Trump and the
First Lady of the United States Melania
Trump
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello America hello
the first lady and I wish each and every
one of you a happy Independence Day on
this truly historic 4th of July today we
come together as one nation with this
very special salute to America we
celebrate our history our people and the
heroes who proudly defend our flag the
brave men and women of the United States
military we are pleased to have with us
vice president Mike Pence and his
wonderful wife Karen we're also joined
by many hard-working members of Congress
acting Secretary of Defense mark Esper
and many other members of my cabinet and
also the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff General Joe Dunford thank you
thank you thank you
Lieutenant General Daniel Hawkinson of
the National Guard and distinguished
leaders representing each branch of the
United States Armed Forces the Army Navy
Air Force Coast Guard Marines and very
soon
the space force
as we gather this evening in the joy of
freedom we remember that all share a
truly extraordinary heritage together we
are part of one of the greatest stories
ever told the story of America it is the
epic tale of a great nation whose people
have risked everything for what they
know is right and what they know is true
it is the chronicle of brave citizens
who never give up on the dream of a
better and brighter future and it is the
saga of thirteen separate colonies that
United to form the most just and
virtuous Republic ever conceived on this
day two hundred and forty three years
ago our founding fathers pledged their
lives their fortunes and their sacred
honor to declare independence and defend
our god-given rights Thomas Jefferson
wrote the words that forever changed the
course of humanity we hold these truths
to be self-evident that all men are
created equal that they are endowed by
their creator with certain unalienable
rights that among these are life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness
with a single sheet of parchment and 56
signatures America began the greatest
political journey in human history but
on that day the Patriots who would
determine the ultimate success of the
struggle were a hundred miles away in
New York there the Continental Army
prepared to make its stand
commanded by the beloved General George
Washington as the delegates debated the
declaration in Philadelphia
Washington's army watched from Manhattan
as a massive British invading fleet
loomed dangerously across New York
Harbor the British had come to crush the
revolution in its infancy
Washington's message to his troops laid
bare the stakes
he wrote the fate of unborn millions
will now depend under God on the courage
and conduct of this army we have
therefore to resolve to conquer or die
days later General Washington ordered
the declaration read aloud to the troops
the assembled soldiers just joined an
excited crowd running down Broadway they
toppled the statue of King George and
melted it into bullets for battle
the faraway King would soon learn a
timeless lesson about the people of this
majestic land Americans love our freedom
and no one will ever take it away from
us
that same American spirit that
emboldened our founders has kept us
strong throughout our history to this
day that spirit runs through the veins
of every American patriot it lives on
and each and every one of you here today
it is the spirit daring and defiance
excellence and adventure courage and
confidence loyalty and love that built
this country into the most exceptional
nation in the history of the world and
our nation is stronger today than it
ever was before it is its strongest now
[Applause]
that same righteous American spirit
forged our glorious Constitution that
rugged American character led the
legendary explorers Lewis and Clark on
their perilous expedition across an
untamed continent
it drove others to journey west and
stake out their claim on the wild
frontier devotion to our founding ideals
let American patriots to abolish the
evil of slavery secure civil rights and
expand the blessings of liberty to all
Americans this is the noble purpose that
inspired Abraham Lincoln to rededicate
our nation to a new birth of freedom and
to resolve that we will always have a
government of By and For the People
our quest for greatness unleashed a
culture of discovery that led Thomas
Edison to imagine his lightbulb
Alexander Graham Bell to create the
telephone the Wright brothers to look to
the sky and see the next great frontier
for Americans nothing is impossible
exactly fifty years ago this month the
world watched in all as Apollo 11
astronauts launched into space with a
wake of fire and nerves of steel and
planted our great American flag on the
face of the moon half a century later we
are thrilled to have here tonight the
famed NASA flight director who led
Mission Control during that historic
endeavor the renowned Gene Kranz
[Applause]
Gina I want you to know that we're going
to be back in the moon very soon and
someday soon we will plant the American
flag on Mars happening Gina it's
happening our nation's creativity and
genius lit up the lights of Broadway and
the sound stages of Hollywood it filled
the concert halls and airwaves around
the world with the sound of jazz opera
country rock and roll and rhythm and
blues it gave birth to the musical the
motion picture the Western the World
Series the Super Bowl the skyscraper the
suspension bridge the assembly line and
the mighty American Automobile it led
our citizens to push the bounds of
medicine and science to save the lives
of millions here with us this evening is
dr. Emanuel Frye ranked when Emanuel
began his work 99 percent of children
with leukemia died thanks largely to dr.
fryer Ike's breakthrough treatments
currently 90% of those with the most
common childhood leukemias survive dr.
you are a great American hero thank you
[Applause]
Americans always take care of each other
that love and unity held together the
first pilgrims it forged communities on
the Great Plains it inspired Clara
Barton to found the Red Cross and it
keeps our nation thriving today here
tonight from the Florida Panhandle is
Tina Belcher her selfless generosity
over three decades has made her known to
all as mrs. angel every time a hurricane
strikes
mrs. angel turns her tiny kitchen into a
disaster Relief Center on a single day
after Hurricane Michael she gave 476
people a warm meal mrs. angel your
boundless heart inspires us all thank
you
[Applause]
thank you very much from our earliest
days Americans of faith have uplifted
our nation this evening we're joined by
sister Deirdre Bern
sister Bern is a retired Army surgeon
who served for nearly 30 years on
September 11 2001 the sister raced to
ground zero through smoke and debris she
administered first aid and comfort to
all today sister Bern runs a medical
clinic serving the poor in our nation's
capital sister thank you for your
lifetime of service thank you
our nation has always honored the heroes
who serve our communities the
firefighters first responders police
sheriff's ice Border Patrol and all of
the brave men and women of law
enforcement
on this July 4th we pay special tribute
to the military service members who laid
down their lives for our nation we are
deeply moved to be in the presence this
evening of gold star families whose
loved ones made the supreme sacrifice
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much throughout our
history our country has been made ever
greater by citizens who risked it all
for equality and for justice 100 years
ago this summer
the women's suffrage movement led
Congress to pass the constitutional
amendment giving women the right to vote
in 1960 a thirst for justice led
african-american students to sit down at
the Woolworth lunch counter in
Greensboro North Carolina it was one of
the very first civil rights sit-ins and
it started a movement all across our
nation
Clarence Henderson was 18 years old when
he took his place in history almost six
decades later he is here tonight in a
seat of Honor
Clarence thank you for making this
country a much better place for all
America
in 1963 Reverend Martin Luther King jr.
stood here on these very steps and
called on our nation to live out the
true meaning of its Creed and let
freedom ring for every citizen all
across our land
America's fearless resolve has inspired
heroes who defined our national
character from George Washington John
Adams and Betsy Ross to Douglas
you know Frederick Douglas the great
Frederick Douglas Harriet Tubman Amelia
Earhart Douglas MacArthur Dwight
Eisenhower Jackie Robinson and of course
John Glenn
it is willed our warriors up mountains
and across minefields it has liberated
continents split the atom and brought
tyrants and empires to their knees here
with us this evening
his Earl Morse after retiring from the
Air Force Earl worked at a VA hospital
in Ohio Earl found that many World War
two veterans could not afford to visit
their memorial on the National Mall so
Earl began the very first honor flights
that have now brought over two hundred
thousand World War two heroes to visit
America's Monument Earl thank you we
salute you thank you
thank you thank you thank you
our warriors from a hallowed roll-call
of american patriots running all the way
back to the first souls who fought in
one american independence today just as
it did 243 years ago the future of
American freedom rests on the shoulders
of men and women willing to defend it we
are proudly joined tonight by heroes
from each branch of the u.s. armed
forces including three recipients of the
Congressional Medal of Honor thank you
they and thousands before us served with
immense distinction and they loved every
minute of that service to young
Americans across our country now is your
chance to join our military and make a
truly great statement in life and you
should do it we will now begin our
celebration of the United States Armed
Forces honoring each branch is unique
culture rich history service song and
distinct legacy I invite acting
secretary please marquez / Secretary of
Defense and chairman Dunford head of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff please join me
[Applause]
in August of 1790 by request of George
Washington and Alexander Hamilton
Congress established a fleet of ten
Swift vessels to defend our shores these
revenue cutters would fight pirates top
smugglers and safeguard our borders they
are the ancestors of our faithful Coast
Guard when our ships were seized in
sailors kidnapped by foreign powers in
1812 it was a Revenue Cutter the Swift
schooner Thomas Jefferson that swept in
to capture the first British vessel of
the war in 1897 when 265 whalers were
trapped in ice and the ice fields of
Alaska were closing up courageous
officers trekked 1500 miles through the
frozen frontier to rescue those starving
men from certain death in 1942 the Coast
Guard manned landing craft for invasions
in the Pacific when the enemy attacked
US Marines from the shores of
Guadalcanal Coast Guard single men first
last Douglas Munro used his own boat to
shield his comrades from pounding
gunfire Munro gave His life hundreds of
Marines were saved as he lay dying on
the deck his final question embodied
devotion that sails with every Coast
Guardsman did they get off
on d-day the Coast Guard's famous
matchbox fleet sir valiantly through
every hour of the greatest amphibious
invasion in the history of our country
one Coxon said the water boiled with
bullets like a mud puddle in hailstone
but still the Coast Guard brave death to
put our boys on Utah and Omaha beaches
every Coast Guardsman is trusted to put
service before all coasties plunge from
helicopters and barrel through pouring
rain and crashing waves to save American
lives they secure our borders from drug
runners and terrorists in rough seas at
high speeds their sharpshooters take out
smugglers engines with a single shot
they never miss when the red racing
stripes of a coast guard vessel break
the horizon when their chopper blades
pierce the sky those in distress know
that the help is on their way and our
enemies know their time has come these
guardians of our waters stand semper
paratus
they are always ready
they are the United States Coast Guard
representing the Coast Guard today you
will soon see an hh-60 jayhawk
helicopter based at Coast Guard Air
Station Clearwater along with an hh-60
five dolphin from Air Station Atlantic
City and an HC 144 ocean sentry from Air
Station Miami
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you to the Coast Guard
on a cold December morning in 1903 a
miracle occurred over the dunes of Kitty
Hawk North Carolina when two bicycle
makers from Ohio defied gravity with a
12 horsepower engine wings made of
cotton and just a few dollars in their
pockets just six years later America was
training its first pilots to take these
magnificent machines up and over the
field of battle in World War one our fly
boys rushed the skies of Europe and aces
like Eddie Rickenbacker filled hearts
and headlines with tales of daring duels
and the clouds general Billy Mitchell
saw the promise of this technology and
risk court-martial in his quest for an
independent air force he was proven
right when empires across the oceans
tried to carve up the world for
themselves and America stood in the way
we wouldn't let it happen
after Pearl Harbor Lieutenant Colonel
James Doolittle and his Raiders flew
b-25 bombers off a carrier deck in the
deep Pacific in a daring feat of
American resolve and as President
Roosevelt said the Nazis built the
fortress around Europe but they forgot
to put a roof on it
so we crushed them all from the air 177
Liberator bombers flew dangerously low
through broad daylight without fighter
protection to [ __ ] the Nazi war
machine at Ploiesti more than 300 Airmen
gave their lives to destroy the enemy
oil refiners and five pilots were
awarded the Congressional Medal of Honor
for their actions in that single raid it
was airman Chuck Yeager who first broke
the sound barrier
it was Airmen like Gus Chris and Buzz
Aldrin who traded their Sabre jets for
rockets to the Stars and it is our
incredible airmen today who wield the
most powerful weapon systems on the
planet earth for over 65 years no enemy
Air Force has managed to kill a single
American soldier because the skies
belong to the United States of America
no enemy has attacked our people without
being met by a roar of thunder and the
awesome might of those who bid farewell
to earth and soar into the wild blue
yonder
they are the united states air force
representing the air force you will soon
see beautiful brand-new f-22 Raptors
from Langley Air Force Base in Virginia
and one magnificent b-2 stealth bomber
from Whiteman Air Force Base in Missouri
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
what a great country in October of 1775
the Continental Congress ordered the
construction of two Swift sailing
vessels each carrying ten cannons and 80
men to sail eastward our young fleet
tested their sea legs against the most
powerful Navy the world has ever seen
John Paul Jones America's first great
naval hero said I wish to have no
connection with any ship that does not
sail fast for I intend to go in harm's
way he got his wish many times when his
ship was shot into pieces off the coast
of England
by a British vessel and her four dozen
guns when demanded to surrender Jones
very famously declared I have not yet
begun to fight
when our Navy begins fighting they
finish the job the war of 1812 Captain
James Lawrence fell with his brothers on
the USS Chesapeake his dying command
gained immortality don't give up the
ship in the Battle of Mobile Bay Admiral
David Farragut lashed himself to the
rigging of his flagship to see beyond
the cannon-smoke crying damn the
torpedoes full speed ahead
in World War two
it was aviators launched from the
carrier enterprise Hornet Yorktown who
filled the skies of Midway and turned
the tide of the Pacific War nobody could
beat us nobody could come close on d-day
çb engineers came ashore to destroy
blockades and barriers making way for
the invasion many lost their lives but
they took the German defenses with them
and our main crushed upon the beaches
like a mighty storm from the naval
demolition units of world war ii arose a
force that became famous in that mekong
delta they don't want to see our force
again the very best of the very best the
Navy SEALs
it was the seals who delivered vengeance
on the terrorists who planned the
September 11th attack on our homeland
it was the seals who stand ready to
bring righteous retribution in mountain
jungle desert to those who do us harm
America's sailors are not born they are
forged by the sea their traditions are
rich with the salt and blood of three
centuries when Old Glory crests the
waves of far insurance every friend and
every foe knows that justice sails those
waters it sails with the United States
Navy representing our great Navy today
will be two f-18 Super Hornets from
Naval Air Station Oceana in Virginia
along with two f-35 Lightning from Naval
Air Station Lemoore in California
[Music]
so great in November of 1775 the
Continental Congress created two
battalions of a new kind of warrior one
who kept and would protect our ships and
sailors and be at home both ashore and
the mast with musket in hand their
versatility was proven in the War of
Independence when 234 Continental
Marines conducted their first amphibious
ray capturing the British supply of
gunpowder and cannons at Fort Nassau
ever since Marines have fought in every
American war their legend has grown and
grown and grown with each passing year
it was the Marines who won America's
first overseas battle vanquishing
Barbary pirates on the shores of Tripoli
their high stiff collar which shielded
them from the pirate sword earned them
the immortal name Leatherneck
it was the Marines who after two long
days of battle marched through the halls
of Montezuma it was the Marines who took
heavy casualties to kick the kaisers
troops out of Bella wood in World War
one earning the title devil dogs and it
was the Marines who raised the flag on
the black sands of Iwo Jima
from the Chosun reservoir to Khe Sanh
from Helmand to Baghdad Marines have
struck fear into the hearts of our
enemies and put solace into the hearts
of our friends Marines always lead the
way after the 1983 Marine barracks
bombing in Beirut which claimed the
lives of 241 great US servicemen Marine
Sergeant Jeff green Ashton lay in
bandages so badly wounded barely alive
when the Commandant of the Marine Corps
came to visit his hospital sergeant Nash
tan had to feel for the generals collar
he wanted to feel his four stars he
could not see and he could not speak he
signaled for pen and paper and with
shaking hand he wrote two words Semper
Fi that motto semper fidelis always
faithful burns in the soul of every
Marine a sacred promise the Corps has
kept since the birth of our country they
are the elite masters of air and land
and sea on battlefields all across the
globe
they are the United States Marines
representing the Marine Corps today will
be a brand new vh 92 soon to serve as
marine 1 along with two v-22 Ospreys
from the famed HM x1 helicopter squadron
at Quantico the night Hawks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
in June of 1775 the Continental Congress
created a unified army out of the
revolutionary forces encamped around
Boston and New York and named after the
great George Washington
commander-in-chief the Continental Army
suffered a bitter winter of Valley Forge
found glory across the waters of the
Delaware and seized victory from
Cornwallis of Yorktown our army man the
amperes it Rand the ramparts it took
over the airports it did everything it
had to do and at Fort McHenry under the
Rockets red glare it had nothing but
victory and when Dawn came their
star-spangled banner waved defiant at
shiloh Antietam and Gettysburg our
soldiers gave the last full measure of
devotion for the true unity of our
nation and the freedom of all Americans
in the trenches of World War one an Army
sergeant named Alvin York faced an
inferno of m-v fire and refused to
retreat he said I won't leave I won't
stop he shot his rifle 18 times killing
18 of the enemy when they fixed bayonets
and charged he killed seven more the
entire German machine gun battalion
surrendered because of one man Alvin
York a generation later the army
returned to Europe and embarked upon a
great crusade with knives and rifles in
hand
the Rangers scale the cliffs of Normandy
the 101st airborne left into the danger
from above illuminated only by enemy
explosions and burning aircraft they
threw back then that's the empire with
lightening of their own from the turrets
of Sherman tanks and the barrels of the
m1 rifle in the darkness of the Battle
of the Bulge with Nazis on every side
one soldier is reported to have said
they've got to surround it again the
poor bastards outnumbered American
warriors fought through the bunkers of
pork chop hill and held the line of
civilization in Korea in the elephant
grass of Vietnam the first cavalry made
it stand amid a forest consumed inflamed
with enemies at every single turn the
army brought America's righteous fury
down to al-qaeda in Afghanistan and
cleared the bloodthirsty killers from
their caves they liberated Phylicia and
Mosul and helped liberate and
obliterator is caliphate just recently
in Syria 100% God through centuries our
soldiers have always pointed toward home
proclaiming this will defend they live
by the Creed of Douglas MacArthur in war
there is no substitute for victory they
are the greatest soldiers on earth
[Applause]
[Music]
nearly 250 years ago a volunteer army or
farmers and shopkeepers blacksmith
merchants and militiamen risk life and
limb to secure American liberty and
self-government this evening we have
witnessed the noble might of the
Warriors who continue that legacy they
guard our birthright with vigilance and
fierce devotion to the flag and to our
great country
now we must go forward as a nation with
that same unity of purpose as long as we
stay true to our coast as long as we
remember our great history as long as we
never ever stop fighting for a better
future
then there will be nothing that America
can not do
[Applause]
thank you we will always be the people
who defeated a tyrant Pross the
continent harnessed science took to the
skies and soared into the heavens
because we will never forget that we are
Americans and the future belongs to us
the future belongs to the brave the
strong the proud and the free we are one
people chasing one dream and one
magnificent destiny we all share the
same heroes the same home the same heart
and we are all made by the same Almighty
God
from the banks of the Chesapeake to the
cliffs of California from the humming
shores of the Great Lakes to the sand
dunes of the Carolinas from the fields
of the Heartland to the Everglades of
Florida the spirit of American
independence will never fade never fail
but will reign forever and ever and ever
so once more to every citizen throughout
our land have a glorious Independence
Day have a great 4th of July
I want to thank the Army Band the
National Park Service the Interior
Department the incredible pilots
overhead and those who are making
possible the amazing fireworks display
later this evening
now as the band plays the Battle Hymn of
the Republic I invite the first lady
vice president and mrs. pence to service
secretaries and military leaders to join
me on stage for one more salute to
America by the famous incredible
talented Blue Angels god bless you god
bless the military and god Bless America
happy 4th of July
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I thank my lucky stars to be living here
today because the flag still stands for
free and they can take
[Music]
[Music]